[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
I'll leave it ready
[ __ ] off the record he loves his
instruments if you haven't noticed I
love him loving his instruments if you
haven't known everybody was that Game of
Thrones he said thank you very much last
night I had a dream that I was swimming
in a hotel what's in your mouth are you
eating it were filming you wanna hear
the funny thing was that no eating thing
was his rule I forgot I had that chip in
my mouth I had a dream that I was I was
swimming in a hotel and then I stood up
and everyone was like oh [ __ ] what's up
hey and then they walked past me and
guess who they saw Tyrion Lannister Oh
Jon Wingull whatever or something yeah
but yeah entourage is it done I don't
know what his real name is the entourage
you know how he's a short dude so like
the entourage almost surrounded him so I
didn't know where he was until the crowd
split and then I saw him like damn I
wish because he's my favorite character
I cannot believe that sure you only get
with rose it's not that I'm like I can
get into it you have to watch it I have
to watch it twice to be like I knew it
like I saw a couple episodes I was like
it seems pretty good but I just have to
watch the first three seasons to get
really into it and there's like a
million characters and then you have to
watch it again yeah cuz you forget
everything to lose track of them yeah
I'm kind of over long series that's why
I only like short series now I don't
think that's a very big what do you
watch for shorts in have you seen the
night of at least yeah the night of
that's a great example like Aamir Khan
he's like he's a he's like the [ __ ]
future dude like Ozark [ __ ] good at
the same time and I couldn't get past it
five minutes that was like it okay I
like it okay
have you seen who is America dude who is
America I saw just just alone the
[ __ ] YouTube clips dying Sasha
barrese oh I haven't seen that yet but
I've seen the clips on there so go Ali G
is like
shows of all time yeah yeah OG show is
like in Sasha burn coal is like one of
my biggest influences he literally got
somebody to [ __ ] bite on a dildo oh
yeah he had a strap-on to his dick and
then so he had a dildo just hanging out
like this and then the guy that he's
teaching is like some he's like some
anti-terrorism like super Posada yeah
yeah and he goes one of way to when you
get to beheading an escaped beheading is
to bite the private and then because
he's like a baby he's holding like some
machete right yeah he goes oh I am Isis
I'm going to behead and then and then
the guy goes and starts biting his dick
like the the funniest I don't know if
it's funny but it's more it's like
concerning and hilarious but he goes he
was basically asking them what they
think that quinceanera is and then do
straight up said he goes well when the
woman who turns 15 or so becomes a woman
and all the men take their turn later
what so they have sex with the other
yeah it's disgusting they all just take
their turns with a yellow and he's like
seriously that's why we should build the
wall yeah [ __ ] wild [ __ ] ugly this is
a real person you just have to go on
Google and look up quinceanera
yeah he got Dick Cheney to sign his
waterboarding kid show his ass and that
will resign yeah that was hilarious that
guy yeah yeah because this this
politician is like super anti like
immigration specifically for Muslim he
doesn't want any more Muslims to come to
America and he has this like paranoia
that every everyone is gonna be like
terrorists or something like that so
then Ali G he he comes out as this
Israeli like special force guy and he
teaches all these guys like
anti-terrorism tactics and one of the
things is oh they're super homophobic so
show them your ass and run into
so I saw it on Eclipse with you didn't
that guy resigned I don't know how you
do that and not laugh like I thought
much of a master Sacha Baron Cohen is he
just embodies his character it becomes
them he is literally the best actor in
the world yeah yeah like legit are
sometimes though and I think guys coming
out with his naked ass I see though I
can't believe this
look I was like I did I was doubting it
but it actually is working I cannot
believe how well this yeah I would be
the whole town's like but I can't
believe everything everyone is agreeing
to what I'm trying to get them to do
I'll crack up in the first two seconds
like I would just be laughing my ass
I'll go home every ever after every TV I
would go I would cry and I'd be like oh
my god life is beautiful so thankful oh
god like [ __ ] crazy well not one of
my favorite ones is like he was telling
this dude like like when you're
surrounded by terrorists you want to
track attention no and he's like I want
to say you want to say crazy stuff right
and he goes so in America there is a
forbidden word it starts with the end
[Laughter]
like no no what are you doing it's not
this word this word is bad oh you crazy
it's nuni shows what's your favorite
woman watch him know I haven't seen you
like hey we'll be last because I don't
remember I'm watching you just go
through it there's something we're not
watching you know you're putting me on
the spot I'm not here in my brief until
after you there's so much pressure I'm
all I'm thinking about is like remember
the show and I'm not even actually
remember the show every yeah me remember
I remembered I'm like the show
looking through our mental Netflix it's
just empty DVD covers like I mean I just
I just finished binge watching and
comedians in cars getting coffee oh
we've been watching for a while too
first only started by watching the
Chappelle one and then like a couple of
Michael's with Louie one and a couple
other ones but then then I was like you
know I'm just gonna watch and I've
learned so many things like there's so
many gems in that show Seinfeld says
that I'm like huh
like one-liners or other comedians a1
letters and I'm like one of my favorite
ones was uh I think they're talking
about how when Chris Rock like he had
his new special and he got together a
louis c.k what's that girl from SNL
Jennifer Tina Fey no the utterson wig
yeah Kristen Wiig two other I think
comedians all from different genres is
to read through his stand-up to see if
he would hit every single demographic
and audience and it's great yeah so
after he got all those people to come
and do that the table read of the set
with them after he was done he bought
all four of them
roley's but then on the fact of the roll
exorcist thank you [ __ ]
and I'm like and then when I watched
Louis CK's stand-up he's wearing the
exact same Rolex that Kristen Wiig is
talking about and I'm like how dope is
it that all of these that Chris Rock can
just drop like 40 GS on four watches but
get in great stuff thank you
[ __ ] yeah didn't we say it to
you though yeah thank you thanks and he
turned it on it says thank you
[ __ ] I'm like oh it does
oh you know what you know the [ __ ] that
happens like in writers rooms or like
when the cameras are off and the [ __ ]
that we can say and play with
hypotheticals I wish I feel like the
world would be such a nicer insane or
place if everyone did that because a lot
of people don't have the same coping
mechanisms that comics do and that's
like one of the greatest ways to control
your darkness comics get through by just
flipping it like just yeah just
laughable perspective thing yes Emily
and I think that's how they work past
and they can let go of a lot of their
like
traumas or anything like yep a lot of
comedians have been through some stuff
and I'm not
the greatest ones have yeah they've been
just through some serious ones are the
most yeah seriously
they usually are if you don't have a
history it's like I don't know I need a
little bit of darkness to my comedy or a
little bit of like attitude or just some
type of it's expected it's just like yes
and that's why like writers rooms have
to be to the face of this like she was
talking about like how SNL she's like I
want SNL to be as diverse as possible
yeah you know and it's like because you
want to be able to hit things that are
like you if you watch a comedy show and
it's like only written by like a certain
people it's like yeah that's funny but
it's not relatable to everyone that
feels like well I know it's I know this
is more relatable to other people and
it's not as relatable to me like Dane
Cook is that yeah that didn't come I
can't mine can connect with him because
I feel like he's only hitting one like
all the white girls oh I want to like
him but I can't like I can't I don't
want to like him at all man I know
Danya yeah I just like the role that he
plays when he's acting because he said
you like clean character the last time I
thought Dane Cook was in Louie when he
sat down with Louie and they had that
talk and I was such a great scene
because I knew I'm like a comedy nerd so
I like was falling all that it's like a
kid you're like whoa what happened like
when Danes career pretty much like
plummeted because people said he copied
like three movies jokes like this is
like canceling before Twitter's really
really seeking like well it's like he's
Daniels like yo I just happen to say
similar jokes cuz they weren't like
exactly the same but they had the
similar premise yeah well like I think
that's like one of the most insulting
things to do is like to copy another cop
oh yeah like comics like but even you
shouldn't get it if you're a comic you
shouldn't just like whatever okay it's
not that it's hard this is what people
understand everybody has similar jokes
but you could tell in the delivery and
the set up if it's this if where you got
it from
oh yeah everybody has literally the same
jokes but it's always personal because
I'm thinking of a name you sure she got
accused but her career is fine also but
see that's one thing like to down
deliver like call of what's-his-name
Carlos Mencia that was deliberate like
he stole it clearly issue
Schumer and then like even Dane Cook I
feel like maybe they heard the joke and
then in their peripheral it was just
there and then they throw like oh this
is funny and they completely forgot that
they heard it somewhere else and it was
Amy Schumer's is bad because it's not
one or two it's like 38 oh really I
didn't mean so there's like but there's
way too many it's like that you just
happened to have picked up that has the
same bit in style hmm so if it was one
or two it's like yeah that happens I
even I just didn't cook yeah Dan cooks
was like only one or two jokes was one
or two Amy Schumer is like a plethora
it's like ridiculous the amount that it
is and so now in today's society like
like people don't even care about the
plagiarizing part which pisses me off
because it's like amen like it matters
because it takes a comic time and time
again to put this up go onstage bomb do
it again rework it reworking rework it I
did all the [ __ ] late where can you
steal my [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I
mean and they don't see that but they're
like oh well it made me laugh so it's
okay it's not [ __ ] okay because this
is somebody's life [ __ ] work and
livelihood dude there was even that one
youtuber girl who took that louis c.k
joker or whatever which i have yeah yeah
that was you know her she's not even a
stand-up you know but even then then her
career spine to which it should be you
know I think Hertz was just I think hers
could have been an accident but she did
steal it and it is what it is but people
just don't care anymore
they're just like well it made me laugh
it's okay I mean what can you do I've
had shits stolen yeah but I've done and
I did care a lot and I made a big deal
out of it and then I was just saying can
you like I think that's why it's so
important at least for comedians to come
with as unique as a perspective as
possible because one they can't steal it
yeah when you tell your true life story
no one can really steal it and then like
one of the best case and one of the best
and sis of that is Bobby Lee like his
[ __ ] is so unique to him that there's no
way anyone can tell the joke about how
he sucked her brother's dick and he got
raped by a Down syndrome guy and get
away with it and go oh wait wait that's
your joke
I don't what no you saw anyone would
want to steal those jokes yeah you're
right he writes jokes that make people
laugh that no one dares to steal I think
if you're asked authentic as possible
and
you hashtag know yourself and you're
like know what you're about in terms of
comedy then like you're gonna be as left
that accessible yeah and you're you're
not gonna be you're not gonna even want
to steal a joke or letting blurred lines
when especially when it comes to like
youtubers and like stand-up stuff right
there's a difference in between you
referencing a joke from a stand-up
comedian in your youtube videos and then
everybody knows that it's that person's
joke
you know yeah yeah that is because if
let's say at a video I was like oh my
god
hey it's not my joke they know we're
laughing together because were they know
I'm talking about Kevin Hart right you
know I mean there's a [ __ ] difference
between you doing that and saying this
video-content was mine you know I mean
then you become the genius behind the
joke and that credit isn't being given
so that's what people are confusing it
to it's like dude you can't just take
that bit and say it's yours like it
doesn't work that way man I wish like
like the community where at least like
that's what you should like roast
somebody for it yeah I mean it's cuz
you're now you're taking somebody's you
should shame people for stealing I think
he's just a big funnel yeah yeah yeah
make fun of them just be like oh that
joke yeah I'm very happy to have written
it for you like I say sure like that
yeah cuz then that's hilarious
yeah because you're combating it was
actually funny something right you're
not like how dare you I demand an
apology boner not like that but roast oh
yeah but like Russell Peters who also
has like issues with Trevor Noah because
of that too because like Trevor Noah I
guess I stole a couple you guys just now
you don't actually I am gonna tell
Russell this under swing you know who
cares yeah cuz like like Tata Stella
Indian jump I think he like fully copied
some bits and then and then even
Russell's like dude what the hell but if
you like oh my bad and then you did it
again
[ __ ] and I get a completely understand
and sympathize with Ross's frustration
but then I'm also like Russell you're
Russell and he's travelling Noah who
cares somebody Sue's her [ __ ] just be
like all right makes a linking it better
like I mean and just roast them for it
yeah and then just make something you
know like I said it might be he's a
writer too like he works on TV he has a
team a right like some of these guys
they just [ __ ] repeat [ __ ] that
they're told and they have a script and
they're pressured and they like steal
jokes or unnecessarily steal jokes
unintentionally your you know what I
mean it's like yeah I was great yeah
David you got [ __ ] up I got [ __ ] up
man can I just say by the way if
anyone's getting made and I was looking
for what does it call a wedding
officiate yeah I was like literally
watching him and I don't think I've ever
seen you live or do anything live like
but I know of you I've seen you on the
internet but like I've never known you I
don't watch a lot of YouTube like I know
I briefly have an idea of like who's
content I would enjoy it I'm YouTube and
you guys that's why I'm here in your
face David if you guys invited me in I
would've been like oh I'd love you know
I'm busy of Roza yonder let's do it hell
yeah anyways back to me gassing him up
yeah so his I was like so impressed cuz
you I told you this to you like walk the
line of like graceful and and hilarious
oh you balance it like and it was like I
was watching you and I was like I was
like let me see it I can't believe he's
continued to do this just cuz I've seen
maybe it's because a lot of Indian
weddings a lot of MCS are so bad and I'm
just like oh god you're so bad like
they're just terrible but like you just
like we're so graceful and you were so
funny at the same time and I was like
I'm so impressed I was like at the end
of it like I was like and then as soon
as you finish those like yes
yeah I'm so happy I was I was like I
want to clap be like yo I told him that
thank you so much that's dumb it's such
a great job cuz I got learned and he was
like teaching life lessons he's talking
about like relationships you sing [ __ ]
yeah don't give them too many cops I'm
gonna gossip when somebody does
something good I will let him know man
and that was like so much really well
done so I think I think you should
literally have a booking Zemo just that
good I was really impressed I just have
to like know the person enough so like
even even for Tim's wedding like it was
a little difficult because I haven't met
Shias family so I didn't know how I can
walk that line you know how far can I
take these jokes because originally with
that with even with the the one that I
like Sam I wrote it out and I just throw
it out the window just because I was
like this is pointless I might as well
just like speak and just say whatever
but there was a lot more jokes in it but
I was like I don't know who her family
well enough so I'm gonna go backwards
that's good and then leave it at that so
it was kind of like a little bit of both
and I saw how hot you guys I thought
everybody doing this and I was like I'm
gonna wrap this [ __ ] up
timing was it was like the perfect
amount of time I saw everybody sweating
I was sweating I was like mmm I'm gonna
give this about seven minutes yeah a lot
of people were saying how thankful they
were it was it was over there really I
think she wanted it a little longer but
she she liked it though she was like 20
minutes I was like wait because it was
like perfect it was like sweet perfect
everything was great and then Hussam
think I'm bein everyone it was just
enough where I went through the dress
shirt I didn't sweat through the actual
suit check we're like check my
Bachelorette well yeah we're good cuz I
opened my suit and I was like [ __ ] my
dress shirt is wet but my suits dry I
felt like chill wincing cuz it was like
Sun in her eye here too and then like I
see Rick's wedding as a song
evaporation because that nipple started
getting a little moisture you started
roasting Ric for know what he called
them out I forgot what did a trash can
theme they taking out that was part I
don't even know I understand the
reference or context but it was so funny
I was like that's fine yeah I know that
that's that's right that's all I do
I know I know Tim and brick okay cuz I
was invited to the wedding so I notice I
just like I'm like nobody needs to
understand that the like intensity of
the relationship and I was like people
understood the jokes arose because
there's this video on Instagram of Rick
something cheers hell of mad because she
told Tim to take out the trash and he
did it and ants came through out there
all brand-new house and she's sittin
there in the tears piss and you never
see a piss and she's just sitting there
she goes you take out the trash or you
know and then tip is just laughing at it
throughout the whole video just cracking
the [ __ ] shot that in that was the
last thing you said right when they were
exchanging read you said something where
gia was like wow I love talking about
her gummy hair vitamins oh yeah yeah
yeah she has a brand deal with the gummy
hair vitamins that always pops up on her
[ __ ] I should know work it does work by
ot time just good for like they can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]